welcome to a new take on the news asking
the hard questions on the subjects that
matter to you
and putting the public at the center of
the national conversation
this is the great debate
each week we'll be getting to the bottom
of the issue dominating the headlines
this week
things we might have thought we'd left
behind
fuel shortages panic buying empty shells
and the specter of a winter of
discontent
our viewers panel will share their
stories have their say
and they'll hold our studio guest to
account and here in the studio joining
us this week
the secretary of state for the
environment food and rural affairs
george eustis
ian wright chief executive of the food
and drink federation
mary starks a former executive director
at the energy regulator ofgem
and dale vince the founder of energy
company ecotricity
with petrol pumps running dry
supermarket deliveries delayed and
prices on the rise
the big question tonight
is britain running on empty so let's go
straight to our viewers panel as we'll
always do
and can we start with people
at the sharp end of the current crisis
the hgv drivers and i'm going to come
first to andy potts
andy you've been a driver for many years
what's your experience of the job in the
past and now
um well nothing's much changed uh
to be honest all of this
what's going on now you know i think
it's a watershed
in the industry because it's it's
bringing to light the conditions of what
people are having to
not only live on but work under
okay thank you andy and now steve
jackson in northampton uh you left the
industry three years ago
why did you leave can you be tempted
back
i
i left because i was fed up of doing 15
14 15 hours and being expected to work
15 hours
um yes i'd like to come back
but unfortunately dvla are still i'm
still waiting for dvla to renew my
license and i have been since may
because i reached the age of 50 i had to
a medical which i did um but i'm still
waiting now
but then i'm expected to watch
grant shap saying that they'll move
heaven and earth which is completely
untrue
um and then they're going to bring in eu
drivers that i could do that job
what would you like grant chaps to do to
accelerate things steve
the thing is there's thousands of uk
lorry drivers that came out of the
industry because of the hours the pay
the conditions
thousands would love to jump back in but
there's so much red tape that the eu
brought in that the uk still follow
through like the cpc's which is a
35-hour course that a lorry driver us to
attend
steve thank you let me go now
to nasheen
amir who i think from blackburn who has
a question for our studio panel good
evening nasheen
hello good evening um i just wanted to
know how we can go from
everything being fine to one day waking
up and there's a fuel crisis no food on
the shelves
um energy crisis like how can we go from
everything being fined to then all of a
sudden having nothing
so panel a question which i think a lot
of people are asking around the country
they want to know
how do we go from everything being
generally okay
to waking up one day to energy fuel and
food shortages well
environment secretary george eustis
how did that happen
well i think the thing to bear in mind
is as we've come out of this pandemic
and this is happening right around the
world there's quite a bit of turbulence
in supply chains generally so there's
been disruption to shipping
we're getting labor shortages in key
sectors um we're getting some disruption
to some of those you know the supply of
hgv drivers and other supply issues so
um some of the goods that manufacturers
would normally import and use they're
finding it harder to get hold of those
so there is a bit of turbulence to come
out of this uh it will settle down but
underneath this particular issue as well
is a specific issue of hgv drivers and i
think steve and andy both made some very
good points about the importance of
seeing wages rise seeing them get a
better work-life balance so they can
spend more time with their family
improving you know infrastructure on the
road so that they can get a shower if
they're staying overnight in their cab
and so on these are the things that
haven't really been addressed
previously and we need to start thinking
about if we're going to attract people
to this sector we will come back to that
but let me come to ian wright just a bit
of turbulence
that's just come up come out of nowhere
well trevor i think this has been
happening for months
we've seen shortages
uh be beginning to appear on shelves
right since the beginning of the spring
and i've been arguing that this is a
structural change we we think that the
food to farm to fork food chain which
normally
employs about four million people is
probably about five hundred thousand
short
that didn't happen overnight there are a
number of factors uh the immigration
policy is some is put some part of it
brexit i suppose is some part of it but
i think it's overdone the real change is
that a lot of people have gone home to
the eu a large number of people like
your two lorry drivers have moved out of
lorry driving some of them into online a
number of different changes there and
the concert and a number of people
economically inactive a half a million
people have just given up work those
changes are structural and they have a
big impact
okay
let me come back to steve jackson
steve
secretary of state says that this is
essentially
a short-term problem
and ian wright says
hey we could have seen this coming
what do you think
this has been i've been a lorry driver
for 24 years this has been coming for
15 20 years
you
you can't it's not an attractive
profession to get into now so the the
older people are retiring
you the eu people are moving back to the
eu
it's not an attractive
job for the younger people to come into
okay let me come back into the studio to
dale vince uh um you
have uh
electricity business uh you've been in
the middle of some of the issues of
energy what do you think
a temporary blip or something that it
heralds a big change for us
in the case of the energy market yep
it's not a temporary blip i would say
a whole bunch of things have come
together and the problems that have been
underlying the industry for a very long
time have come to a head and we can see
that we're utterly dependent on foreign
markets for our energy suppliers of oil
and gas
and what we really need to be doing is
making our own here and in the process
creating a great number of very good
long-term sustainable jobs it makes a
great deal of sense to do that because
we spend 50 billion pounds a year
bringing fossil fuels to our country
just to burn them we don't need to do
that we can make the electricity and gas
that we need right here from renewable
energy and fight the climate crisis at
the same time
mary starks to some extent when you were
of gem
this issue of policy about how we deal
with long-term energy needs whether we
get more energy from abroad or whether
we can generate
more
here was in your hands do you agree
with dale that we could have done better
i certainly agree that the direction of
travel is towards generating more
electricity renewably and we've made
enormous strides in doing that over the
past couple of decades but it is a it's
a big road to travel and we've still got
a lot further to go
what when you say we've got
a lot more to go
go along the road
where would you what direction would you
be heading in what's on that road so we
need to uh remove fossil fuels entirely
from our energy system
we've made enormous strides in cutting
down the amount of carbon our energy
system uh
emits by switching from coal to natural
gas but we now need to wean ourselves
off natural gas and onto renewable
energy and
and really make the system work with
with those intermittent renewables okay
let me come back to you uh nuchine
you've heard all our four studio guests
on
your question and it seems to come down
to an issue of whether you think
this thing is going to go away and we're
going to get over it or whether we're
seeing a really basic shift in the way
that we're going to have to live who
convinces you
um
no one to be honest i don't understand
why if a couple of people have said that
you know um
it was a long time coming or they could
foresee it happening why was nothing put
in place why have we got to this stage
in the first place
okay look we're going to return to this
longer term question long-term
short-term question a little later in
the show but i want to deal with
something that's happening this evening
um we've heard that surrey county
council is considering declaring a major
incident for its public services and
that means that key workers in areas
such as the nhs and the police will get
priority access to fuel you show your
card you get
uh to the head of the queue and i'd like
to find out what
as a whole our viewers panel thinks on
this
so let me come to the wall
should key workers get access to fuel
over other people can i see those who
agree
that key workers should get priority
over everybody else
hands up please
i can see quite a
i can see a lot of hands going up there
this sounds yeah this looks like a this
looks like a policy that
uh somebody in government might want to
adopt but let's before we
test that let me come to sharon dillon
on our viewers panel uh and sharon you
work in the nhs
what did you think i think you had your
hand up
yes um i mean i would like to think that
key workers would have priority because
it makes common sense we've got to keep
the country going but remember this
situation wasn't our making
um we didn't ask for this situation and
it is
you know it is a direct failing of the
government that we've got at the moment
absolutely direct failing and they take
responsibility for that i mean the
question i i'm you know i haven't seen
any i haven't seen worries at the moment
no one's come forward where is boris
where why do you not come forward you
know we're a national crisis here nhs
workers have got enough to cope with and
we should now have to be now putting our
card forward just to get fuel it's not
fair we didn't ask for this situation
and we should not you know be putting
this put
put out there that we've got to do these
things so you know government ministers
got a lot to answer for and i think we
need answers and we need them quick
and we need a solution sharon i i can't
answer the question about quite where
the prime minister is tonight but i
think we have to imagine that he's
speaking
through the secretary of state uh george
eustis um let's just deal with the
immediate question george eustis
why
can't you give key workers priority it's
clearly something that would be popular
well i can understand why people would
have sympathy for that argument but
actually the real solution
uh is to um calm you know calm the
situation down and get people buying
fuel normally again the truth is that
there is no shortage of fuel we have the
same amount of fuel being produced in
refineries in this country same amount
of fuel uh in uh you know in storage and
also deliveries have kept going you know
there's been some shortages what's
actually caused this current issue with
cues at filling stations and filling
stations running out is that there's
been a panic buying episode we saw that
during the covet situation as well we
saw on saturday sales of petrol
increased by about 50
over norms now it started to ease down
it's now down to about 20 above and also
people are coming down and as those who
are anxious fill their tanks we will see
this calm down and the focus of the
government is to try to get things back
into normal order calm people down allow
the supply chains to move but with
respect you've been saying that for a
week
and there are two points i think which
are made one is that
there may be enough fuel in the country
as a whole
but a lot of it is in the wrong places
and secondly
people have been driving past petrol
stations which are dry since last week
this hasn't happened until saturday
so you can't really blame the consumers
for this can you well i'm not blaming
the consumer what i'm saying is what
happened is on around thursday of last
week
there were some
four courts that announced that they
didn't have enough distribution to be
able to get to all their forecasts so
they closed some of them it's a very
small number uh overall
that then got widespread coverage in the
media and i don't blame the media that's
what the media do but as a result of
that we then saw you know panic buying
and a surge in demand of 50 that's
what's caused this issue and it's only
really when just as we saw with the food
panic buying episode early in the
pandemics only when we get over that
that things will return to another okay
let's just deal with tonight's issue
do you agree
with what seems to be coming out of
surrey and what clearly is the
view of our
viewers panel that key workers should
get priority well it'll be an individual
uh really individual businesses will
will sort of make that decision when we
had issues with food supply during the
pandemic some retailers chose for
instance to have a an hour at the day
where they prioritized nhs workers uh
and the elderly uh it's possible that
some will choose to do that but you know
the focus of the government is actually
to get
enough supplies there so that we don't
have to do that but businesses will be
looking at government and
what they will want to know is if they
decided to do that would the government
feel that that was an okay thing to do
or would the government say this is
another way of winding up the panic
no it would it's a it's something that
they did so some are already for
instance some uh petrol garages are
already putting a limit uh on sales or a
30 pound cap on what can be bought now
there's two sides of that on on the one
hand it potentially makes the petrol
they've got go further and the fuel
they've got go further in a situation
where people are panic buying but
there's also a problem that it could
exacerbate cues and that people join the
queue at one filling station
on balance i think these things over
complicate things and what we should be
focusing on is getting people back to
behaving uh normally refueling in a
normal way and making sure that we get
those supplies into that we're leaving
no stone unturned to ensure we can do
that let me come back to you sharon
dillon um secretary of state's
not opposed to but he's pretty lukewar
warm about the idea of key workers
getting priority what do you feel about
that
i mean
he's
i mean he said a lot of things at the
end of the day i mean
i mean where's the leadership i mean
where why you know
you all you've stated so far is it's a
media it's that it's it's the customers
taking too much at the end of the day
you know where is your leadership and
where are you stating where do we stand
as key workers are you going to give us
priority yes or no i mean why is he left
to the individual for court to decide
again why can't the government now make
a decision and do something constructive
instead of blaming
everybody else not actually looking at
themselves because it is their feeling
we should not be put in this situation i
should not have this conversation with
you right now but i am because you
failed simple you simply failed
you failed the answer is to as i said
get the no
but she's saying come on she heard that
she's saying make a decision
tell us that you're in favor or not
don't go don't go missing well what i'm
saying is uh i don't think it's helpful
to over complicate things and what we
should be focused on is making sure that
we get the supplies back in to these
garages and actually get the demand
levels down to normal levels it's
already gone from a 50 increase down to
yesterday it was about 20 above normal
levels there's signs that this is
calming down now and that people are
getting back to normal buying habits as
soon as they do uh this situation will
be resolved dale
what do you make of this
yeah would you agree with that with our
viewers panel i agree absolutely with
the u.s panel it is the job of
government to take responsibility for
this and i think through the pandemic we
saw the government blame the public
several times for the spread of the
virus i think to blame panic buying now
i mean there's a point to it is a
contributing factor but the public lacks
confidence in the government and in
supply chains there's a reason for that
thank you let's take a short pause there
coming up
it's what we're seeing a short-term
spasm or could it be the start of a
bigger change in our way of life
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking whether britain is running
on empty
one of the big questions for us all is
of course
how long will the current crisis last
could it even be part of a permanent
shift
well let me go now to the wall
to
mansa wood ando mansa i think you have a
question for the studio
yeah um so it's basically is clovid or
brexit basically to blame for the
shortages and would have problems
continue
uh have you got a view about that mantra
um i personally do i feel like um kobe
definitely exasperated um the whole
situation but i definitely feel with
brexit as a whole it definitely
contributed um and i think just
basically the fact that we're now trying
to grant visas from the eu countries to
come back kind of
you know highlights the point of
why he shouldn't have gone ahead to
begin with
okay man so thank you very much um okay
let's go back to the wall here there's a
plain speaking east londoner
who says
bit of cove bit of uh brexit but she's
pretty clear kobe uh really made the
difference let me ask you first can i
see those who think that the big
difference here accepting both things
have made a difference the big
difference here has been made by kovid
can i see hands up who think that it's
covid that's really made the difference
and
as a smaller number a small smaller
number maybe a third to a half okay you
can put your hands down can i ask those
who think that it's brexit that's made
the big difference here
can i see hands up who think that is
yeah it looks to me like um our viewers
panel is saying
it's probably sixty
sixty percent brexit and 40 percent
covered
um
let me go back let's go let's go back to
manchester's question and uh come to our
studio guest
are the shortages
uh can we down to covet
or down to brexit
so
who's gonna uh uh to this first
dale
ian's a big bun ian sure uh well i would
argue that it's both but also much more
than that so i think that that brexit
has played a part it's played a part in
1.4 million european workers who left
because of kovid went home not coming
back with the enthusiasm that we would
have hoped that's a big hole in the
workforce but it's also the case that
covid has accelerated lifestyle changes
which people were making anyway so a
number of people something like half a
million the bank of england says have
decided to become economically inactive
they've chosen to give up work because
they liked their lifestyle during the
lockdowns and after the lockdowns and
then you've got a change in the
character of foreign students in the uk
who before the 2016 vote were
predominantly european and eu citizens
who chose to work their way through
college and often in hospitality or
other jobs associated with the food
supply chain now many of those students
are chinese in origin and they don't
work their way through now all these
changes are social changes which have
have have happened and probably would
have been would have been happening
anyway they've been accelerated and the
thing that we need to grapple with and i
think george and the government need to
grapple with is that these changes may
well be permanent and if they are
permanent that means there's a gap in
our workforce that we need to address
and the immigration policy that was
designed for a different kind of
workforce pre-brexit in terms of policy
making is now in my view not fit for
purpose
could we have seen it coming
so i i think on the
could we have seen this particular gas
price spike coming not necessarily but
that you know wholesale energy prices do
that so we could totally have foreseen
that that things would would would go up
from time to time and it has played into
some underlying structural weaknesses in
in the uk energy sector which you know
we we could have chosen to fix for sure
uh
dale vince do you think that we could
have seen particularly the gas uh
the gas spike coming
i think we could i think we've seen it
before
i think the fact is for me in the energy
market it's neither brexit nor covered i
think the north sea is running on empty
we're down to about 50 of our energy now
from the north sea so we're much less
energy independent than we were at its
peak we've seen that coming for decades
in this particular crisis we had two
nuclear power stations go down they
didn't come out of scheduled maintenance
at the end of the summer at the same
time the summer was the least windy for
60 years so our wind fleet which picks
up
30 percent of our national supply now
that underperformed we have a cable that
connects us we have six cables
connectors to the continent one of those
burned down so we couldn't bring
electricity in from france all of that
created an electricity shortage and so
we turned to gas to fill the gap at the
same time as the rest of the world was
turning to gas so that's ultimately the
problem and the russians have turned
down supplies to europe by 25 for
political reasons so but but it starts
fundamentally with a shortage of
electricity that we have which is a
structural one and then we turn to gas
at the same time coincidentally as
everybody else
george eustis
there's some things that can't be
predicted they're what they call black
swan events and so on
but there's a huge machinery that sits
in government trying to work out what
the risks are
and we've heard from dale that some of
the energy risks could at least have
been envisaged
and we've heard from ian that some of
the labor force risks post
brexit should certainly have been
foreseen
government asleep at the wheel well when
you get a major shock like the pandemic
we've been through it's notoriously
difficult to predict what will happen
it's not that long ago only nine months
ago that all the economists were saying
we might have four million unemployed
now that had that never happened uh
thank god it didn't but what we actually
have instead is one million job
vacancies um now even i knew that brexit
would have an impact on european
migrants this country that a lot of them
would go home we must have been able to
see that we also knew that millions of
them some four or five million had gone
for settled eu status now in the event
what's happened is about 1.4 million of
those chose to return home because of
lockdown because of the pandemic they
wanted to be nearer their families and
it's a big question as to whether they
will come back or not so i i take issue
with this thing that this was all uh
predictable i don't think it was
everybody was the range has been from
you know a million job vacancies to
possibly four million unemployed it is
difficult to predict but i think ian's
made another important point which is
what's definitely happened is during the
pandemic during lockdown people have
sort of reappraised a bit their
work-life balance they've had more time
with family and in the case of hgv
drivers and a lot of them are in their
50s they had more time with their family
and a lot of them thought you know what
i just don't want to get back to that
lifestyle i'm going to take a different
job doing a delivery van job more you
know locally or something
and that's been a choice that they've
made so these are you know there's a
whole combination of things that are
going on here and when it comes to the
electricity market look we've we've
reduced our carbon emissions by 40 by
massive expansion of offshore wind we're
gonna have another five-fold increase in
that in the next decade or so
and we we do get most of our gas either
domestically produced or from norway
from trusted uh partners
george
if i may just quickly make one point
all this makes a lot of sense but there
is a slight tendency for government
ministers i spoke to one your carly
grant grant shaps yesterday
to answer every question with the
suggestion that somehow the population
is at fault they've made some rather bad
choices about how they respond to
covered or how they respond to the
petrol shortages and so on
it's it's that's not a great look for a
government to be telling its own people
you've all been a bit naughty and if you
hadn't been so naughty then we wouldn't
have this problem well i'm not saying
anyone's been naughty actually in many
ways it's a perfectly natural thing for
people to you know reappraise them
there's lots of heads nodding
an htv driver to think that they want to
spend more time with their family to use
that time in lockdown to reappraise
their work-life balance in many ways
that's the most natural thing in the
world and so what we actually need to do
is rather than just saying that more
immigration is the answer to all these
things we probably need to think about
some of the structural issues in this
area how do we attract people to that
sector what do we need to pay them we
need to sort of uh bring more dignity to
some of these jobs you know there's a
lack of patience for um
hgv drivers on the roads motorists you
know don't tolerate the fact that they
block up the race and so on when they're
trying to get goods through the system
we've got to get much more you know
respect for them
well and when they go to supermarkets
people on their back about being late
you know we've got to have quite a
culture change uh to in order to
appreciate some of these roles more and
we don't necessarily do that by opening
the door to lots more immigration
sometimes it does need higher wages and
better working conditions okay
time for a short break when we come back
it isn't just food and fuel that's
running short
this week furlough and the 20 pound
uplift in universal credit come to an
end
will that leave the wallets of millions
of people empty too
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate
and for millions of people in britain
empty petrol stations and empty
supermarket shelves
aren't the only concerns on their minds
right now
it's their finances as well
this week two planks of the financial
support put in during the pandemic uh
come to an end the furlough scheme
and the 20 pounds uplift to universal
credit
let's go to the wall
connor summerall
who is 15 years old connor
what are your thoughts on the ending of
furlough and the changes to universal
credit
i think it's awful
what the government are doing now
they're pulling both safety blankets
from people who really need them at the
same time
and i think it's going to come down to
some families they can afford to eat or
heat their homes
is it right to change universal credit
and end furlough now
let me come first to
ian
is it right to cut universal credit
well i don't know if i know the answer
to that i certainly think that the the
kind of cliff edge of moving from the
current situation to having no universal
credit uplift is a really concerning
matter at a time of relatively high food
price inflation i think that is a worry
for people on fixed incomes and with
with limited incomes and i also think
that the uncertainty created by the the
current debate on shortages will worry
people on fixed incomes my concern is
also that that one of the things that is
happening is in my view an erosion of
our just-in-time food delivery process
our food supply process that doesn't
mean we're ever going to run out of food
we are not going to run out of food big
red letters double underlined um
but
the problem could be that people who are
economically remote and geographically
remote could start to be discriminated
against by the system and those are are
predominantly people on universal credit
so if it were up to me i wouldn't end it
mary um when you
were
running policy
a big part of the responsibility there
must have been
what level would we set price caps on
how do we deal with people who are
extremely poor
uh in fuel poverty and so on
what do you think this uh removal
of the yes temporary uh
20 pound increase is going to do to that
group of people that you used to worry
about
so i mean i think it's uh the timing is
very difficult i think coming into a
winter where we're definitely going to
see
energy bills increase they're going to
go up by about 140 pounds next month and
then we can expect further increases
into the spring
um
you know as ian said there's also food
price inflation so i think there's a
it's it's a very difficult thing to
remove uh universal credits the
universal credit uplift uh coming into a
kind of cost of living squeeze um
well you know when i was off gem we
worried enormously about fuel poverty
and affordability of home heating we
nobody wants to see households having to
choose between heating and eating
but the government does have a range of
measures to help people in really acute
situations um keep the lights and the
heating on so there's there's the warm
home discount there are um there are
there's forms of help available from
from energy suppliers so i hope that
people who are in that very acute um
kind of crisis will will get help this
winter uh
george uses
we've heard from ministers that this was
always going to be temporary everybody
should know that
but of course
when we come to the reality it's never
quite as straightforward as that um
is there any conversation going on in
government about
doing anything to mitigate the impact
of uh this cut well i think the first
thing you bear in mind both of these
things were temporary measures to deal
with the pandemic and we spent hundreds
of billions of pounds on interventions
to try to get us through this pandemic
the question uh asked
specifically about furlough i mean the
early part of this program was all about
labor shortages so there can be no
justification for carrying on furlough
at this point we need people to get back
to work there are a million job
vacancies if they want a better paid job
they can probably get one because wages
are on the the rise and so we do need
people to come off furlough and play
their part back in the economy because
that's one of the uh the issues that
we've got
in the case of universal credit look
this is always going to be difficult but
it was always a
a temporary rise and you have to look at
in the context that wages are rising
that we have kept in place some of the
other supports so local housing
allowances for those with particular
needs and child allowances some of those
have been kept in place but we were
never going to be able to you know
afford this indefinitely to keep it
there indefinitely that would cost
around six billion pounds that's the
equivalent of a penny on tax and having
spent hundreds of billions of pounds to
get through this pandemic there does
come a time when you do have to take
some difficult uh decisions to try to
get our economy back to normal and you
know the positive thing there is that
wages are rising the changes we've made
in recent years enough to get people
back in heavy hev vans are they no well
they they will continue to rise i've
seen salaries quoted in some cases of
getting up to sort of seventy thousand
some loyal jobs i think that's an
exception rather than the rule but they
are uh rising and when i talk to for
instance people in indian sect in the
food uh food processing sector many of
them in the last year have increased
their pay and wages by 10 10 or more
let me go back to the wall um
wayne taylor
i know that you've thought quite a lot
uh about this issue of universal credit
what did you make of what the secretary
of state just had to say
i totally agree with him absolutely
agree with him i mean it was supposed to
be a temporary measure
and i i think it's gone on long enough
and it should be removed um
to me the taxpayer shouldn't be
subsidizing people's lives um but i also
think that the whole system itself needs
a radical change over
um because you've got people who can
work and don't but you've also got
people who don't work because they can't
work and they don't get enough out
i think the system is very easy
for the um for the needy but it's also
difficult for the ones who need that
help so to me
um
in a nutshell the ones who can work they
need to work and just remember there's a
lot of jobs jobs out there especially
truck jobs and with great salaries that
are going begging thank you let me come
to jennifer griffiths who is from the
group excluded uk which was formed to
support those not eligible for
government support during the pandemic
um
what are you hearing jennifer both from
the people who are part of your group
and uh what you think about what's being
said here in the studio
and i i think it's it's very easy for
people to just simplify um the system um
i'm director of member welfare excluded
uk so i deal with not just the financial
implications
of these decisions but also the mental
health implications of these decisions
um i think that the 20
pound universal credit uplift it was a
temporary measure it was advertised as a
temporary measure we knew all the way
along that the government was supplying
that um to get us through covert 19 and
however with the other price hikes that
are going up um as well um the
combination of all these things going on
together and i i think that uh it's just
it's terrible what i mean
i was talking to one of your producers
one of the case studies that i've got um
we've got a lady who was
a school teacher a supply teacher
um and
she
has two young children uh because she's
a sly teacher as soon as play with 19
hit obviously all those uh jobs went
because the schools are shut she's now
on uc and uh food bank donations she's
had to sell a house uh living with her
elderly parents and she's had to spend a
lot of the toys
to stay afloat jennifer um can i say
those who think it is right
to remove the 20-pound uplift
can i see hands those who
agree with wayne that it is right at
this time to remove that 20-pound uplift
i think yeah maybe that out of 100
there's 15 20. those who think that it
is wrong to remove that 20 pound uplift
this week
can i see those hands in
yeah there's an extremely clear majority
that actually
whatever
whatever
the
cost here
a majority of people here
think this is the wrong thing to do
to meet the financial
situation that's set up by the
chancellor do something else don't do
this
well
you know all i can say is i i disagree
with those who think it's the wrong
thing to do i know it's a difficult
thing it's a majority yes and it's a
difficult thing to do and there's no
doubt as uh as was pointed out removing
uh a benefit uh from people but albeit
knowing that it it's always a temporary
one there's never going to be an easy
time to do that but you know doing it at
a time when wages are rising and in the
context of recent years we've we've
doubled for instance the tax-free
threshold we've introduced things like
the national living wage which is given
four thousand pounds a year extra
tonight let's introduce it it was here
before you got there well there was a
national minimum wage we introduced the
national uh living wage uh statutory one
over and above that okay and those
increases have given the lowest paid uh
a boost in incomes in recent years but
yeah fundamentally the job market is in
a very very healthy strong place wages
are rising you know we need um some of
those economically inactive people to
get engaged again in the labor market
and it's a terrible thing that around 40
of people who claim universal credit are
working so they are working but they're
not being paid enough for the work they
do and that's what needs to change
we'll take a short pause there next up
in these extraordinary times
do we have the leaders we need
[Applause]
is britain running on empty that's the
topic of this week's great debate
either way these are historic times
so how will history judge those in
charge
frank solarz uh you're in essex
what's your take on that question of
leadership
well i think there's there's a lack of
leadership um
this government knows the price of
everything but the value of nothing
why do footballers have more compassion
than government ministers
well that's a zinger panel do you agree
with frank the government that the
government is lacking compassion
and he compares
ministers to footballers i think we are
talking marcus rashford here before i
come to you george you used to stale
vince
what do you think
i agree with frank absolutely the
government does lack compassion to say
that it's a very hard thing to take 20
quid a week away from somebody that
really needs it lacks compassion it's
actually much harder to have that 20
quid taken away from you and we have the
money we can find the money today we
heard from the shadow chancellor that
labor will end tax breaks worth 170
billion pounds a year to some of the
richest people in our country we have
plenty of money we just don't put it
where we should do
ian right
we don't have the right leaders
they lack heart
well i think we have great leaders but
not necessarily all of them in
government uh i think we have uh
would you like to name some names well
i'm gareth southgate for example and uh
and dale himself i mean we have great
leaders in business we have great
leaders in sport we have great leaders
across our society many of them in in
very very challenging roles in the nhs
and in voluntary organizations i i'm not
sure that we can label our politicians
in quite the way that
the questioner would i mean i think
ministers have very difficult choices
and they're very constrained sometimes i
think they make the wrong choices i
would not be going out there as the
gentleman you interviewed interviewed
yesterday saying don't panic mr
mannering because normally that has
quite a lot of consequences
but i think that the i think that the
role of leaders has come out during
kovid and i think something perhaps that
politicians could learn from is the
leaders in other sectors mary um you had
a lot to do with government and you're
out of it now
we've got the leaders that we
really need are the best people in our
leadership
i mean
my view on this is that a lot of the
problems we're facing uh today have a
long history and and very many parents
so there are decisions that have
informed the shape of the in the energy
industry that go back years
you know we um for example as a country
we have very very little gas storage
compared to many of our continental
neighbors we have something like two
percent of our annual um gas needs in in
storage capacity compared to
25 30 percent uh on the continent that
decision is is
years if not decades old and that's come
back to bite us now so i don't think
it's just a question of judging today's
current crop
uh george us i'm not going to make a any
personal remarks there's been quite
enough personal remarks lately about
conservative ministers but
is there a problem here that
the country doesn't think the government
really
knows it
or cares about it enough
well it won't surprise you to know that
i i strongly disagree with uh frank on
your on your program and on a good day
um ian will actually occasionally pay me
a compliment for the work that we do in
uh in defra but i think what i would say
is i completely reject the idea that
we've lacked compassion during this
pandemic we spend around 400 billion
pounds in order to help the country
through through the furlough scheme
support for businesses to to keep them
going support for people on low incomes
since then we've had the great success
of the vaccination program where we've
been one of the most successful
countries in the world that's enabled us
to come out of lockdown sooner than most
countries in the world and it's given us
the strongest growth in the g7 as a
result that is good leadership
thank you very much uh
i wish we had a lot more time but we
don't that's all we've got time for
today it just remained for me to thank
our panelists here in the studio uh dale
vince mary starks george eustis and ian
wright
and i want to thank particularly all the
people on our viewers panel for joining
us and being such a great panel
and you can wave goodbye to our to our
watchers if you like
thank you so much guys been terrific
well they all look like they'll be
continuing the conversation hopefully
you'll be doing the same at home thank
you for watching
we'll see you again for next week's
great debate
[Music]